why don't the authors of original books
write original screenplays the sad fact
is that most of us do not have that
talent for the concise and demanding art
form and tonight we honor those who do
have that talent for the Best Original
Screenplay the nominees are robert
Getzel for Alice doesn't live here
anymore
robert towne for Chinatown Francis Ford
Coppola for the conversation Francois
Truffaut Jean le Rashad and Suzanne
Shipman for day for night Paul Mazursky
and Jost Greenfeld for Harry and Tonto
and there's a reward for their
originality the winner is Robert Towne
if if you've ever been on a film that
didn't didn't quite work out you you
know how much you owe to the people on a
film that did and so I can only
reiterate my gratitude toward everybody
who worked on the film toward Fay and
Roman and especially to Robert Evans who
put us all together in to Jack who's
really magic
there's a long line standing at the box
office of the Huntington Hartford
Theatre in Hollywood because an
international star opens there tomorrow
night and Hedda Gabler
she is the accomplished villain
delineator of drama pageantry romance
and comedy she won the Oscar last year
for her brilliant performance in touch
of class welcomed her to her first
Academy Award presentation the glorious
Glenda Jackson
thank you thank you twice in fact and
thank you for tonight